nous sommes en 1780 Kraus un ami de Kant
se rend à une réception en plein air
beaucoup de profs de l'Université de
kenigberg sont présents dans la
conversation il se demande quelle est la
philosophie qui domine actuellement
Kraus dit que Kant a sur son bureau un
manuscrit celui de la Critique de la
raison pure qui va faire suer les
philosophes là les profs rigolent quand
est un touriste si une révolution doit
se produire en philosophie ce n'est
certainement pas lui qui va la
faire
si vous avez entendu parler de Kant
alors vous savez probablement que dans
l'histoire de la philosophie il y a un
avant et un après Kant avant lui les
philosophes élaboraient des systèmes
sans même s'interroger sur leur capacité
à produire des connaissances fiables
après Kant ils ne peuvent plus négliger
le fait que la réalité dont on tire la
connaissance est en partie une
construction de l'esprit quant
représente donc une rupture majeure dans
l'histoire de la pensée occidentale au
point que lorsqu'il faut renommer la
ville où il a vécu kenxberg après la
chute de l'URSS les aut autorité
hésitent à choisir Kant aurade ce qui
signifie ville de Kant en russe c'est
vous dire son prestige et pourtant à son
époque personne ne Paris sur lui
écoutez-moi jusqu'au bout et vous
comprendrez comment un touriste entre
guillemets a fini par rivaliser avec
Platon et
Aristote le père de Kant est artisan
celler ce qui signifie qu'il fabrique et
répare des équipements pour les chevaux
il appartient à une guilde l'association
qui définit les règles de son métier et
quand par sa seule naissance est membre
de cette guilde l' vous l'avez compris
c'est que Kant est destiné à reprendre
l'atelier de son père à l'époque il n'y
a pas de dilemme d'orientation
professionnelle le métier passe trit
souvent de père en fils seulement le
pasteur de la famille se rend compte que
le fils de 7 ans est un garçon bien
spécial le petit Kant a un gros
potentiel intellectuel et le pasteur ne
veut pas gâcher ce potentiel donc il en
parle aux parents il les persuade
d'inscrire leur fils au collège royal
Frédéric une des écoles les plus
réputées de toute la Prusse cette école
va préparer le petit C à des études
ultérieures de théologie ce qui est le
parcours normal des intellectuels de
l'époque mais comment expliquer que Kant
manifeste un potentiel intellectuel si
tôt son père est artisan mais pas un des
artisanats les plus prestigieux et sa
famille appartient à la petite
bourgeoisie donc c'est pas comme si Kant
avait grandi dans une marmite
intellectuelle il a forcément reçu une
stimulation intellectuelle précoce mais
quelle est la source et bien c'est
probablement sa mère en effet la mère de
Kant comme celle de Hegel d'ailleurs la
mère de Kant est une femme plus éduquée
que les femmes de l'époque dès qu'il
faut écrire quelque chose dans la
famille c'est elle qui s'en occupe elle
initie donc son fils au travail
intellectuel et elle le fait si bien que
vers 7 ans le pasteur qui est une figure
d'autorité morale et intellectuelle dans
la communauté lorsque quant a 7 ans le
pasteur estime que ça serait dommage
d'en faire un artisan et que le petit a
le potentiel pour une formation
intellectuelle d'élite après si le rôle
de la mère de Kant a été décisif
l'environnement familial plus
généralement est aussi important dans la
petite bourgeoisie artisanale de
l'époque on valorise le travail bien
fait régulier et rigoureux le petit Kant
apprend donc très tôt à faire des
efforts fort et à s'appliquer et cette
discipline lui sera bien utile parce
qu'au collège Frédéric il n'arrête pas
de bûcher il fait énormément de latin et
il se familiarise avec les classiqu à 17
ans il est admis à l'université de
kenigberg comme
prévu le talent de Kant se manifeste
déjà à l'université les autres étudiants
se rendent compte de sa supériorité
intellectuelle donc il se forme déjà
autour de lui un petit groupe de quasi
disciples sa culture sa discipline et sa
capacité de travail les fascin comme il
est très bon et sympa quant mentor
certains étudiants en gros il les
guident dans leur travail intellectuel
c'est gratuit seulement pour ses amis ce
qui est déjà sympa pour les autres c'est
payant donc quand mononey sa compétence
intellectuelle assez tôt sa rémunération
est sonnante et tribuchante mais
certains tutorés le payent en nature par
exemple avec du café ou du pain c'est
qu'à l'époque Kant ne roule pas sur l'or
et du coup une fois qu'il a fini
l'université à 24 ans il est face à un
problème très concret comment gagner sa
croûte son père vient de mourir et
laisse un héritage mais une une fois les
dtes réglées il ne reste pas grand-chose
et ce pas grand-chose doit permettre de
prendre soin des frères et sœurs de Kant
donc Kant n'est pas rentier
contrairement à descart ou chopenhower
il voudrait bien enseigner à
l'université mais les places sont rares
en plus d'être mal payé et puis il est
trop jeune pour prétendre à une place
fils d'un petit artisan il n'a pas non
plus le réseau pour décrocher un poste
dans l'administration du coup il n'a
qu'une seule option comme tous les
pauvres letttré fraîchement sortis de
l'université comme ça sera également le
cas de Hegel Kant n'a pas le choix il
doit trouver une place de précepteur
Hofmeister en allemand il est d'abord
plusieurs années chez un prêtre aisé qui
le charge de trois de ses cinq fils
ensuite encore plusieurs années chez un
grand propriétaire terrien et enfin chez
le compte kaiserlink le fait que Kant
soit précepteur aussi longtemps n'est
pas anodin ça signifie qu'il est dans le
besoin que l'argent est un souci
constant pour lui dans la vingtaine et
la trentaine il ne pense pas à
révolutionner la philosophie sa priorité
est de vivre de son
savoir nous sommes dans la seconde
moitié des années 1 1750 c'est le début
de la trentaine pour Kant cela fait
quelques années qu'il a soutenu sa thèse
de philosophie à l'université de
kenigberg là même où il a étudié il a
obtenu son doctorat ce qui l'autorise
désormais à donner des cours à
l'université donc après ces années de
préceptorat sa carrière universitaire
démarre enfin mais ses amis se
scandalisent pourquoi se met-il à vendre
ses livres pas lui un intellectuel si
brillant il ne peut pas se séparer de
ses livres et puis pourquoi est-ce qu'il
met toujours le même manteau il est
foutu ce manteau il serait bien qu'il en
change ses amis veulent lui en offrir un
nouveau Kant refuse il veut garder son
honneur mais les premières années de sa
carrière à l'Université de Kenigsberg
sont compliquées financièrement il
n'arrive toujours pas à joindre les
debouts en fait c'est normal comme il
vient d'arriver il ne touche pas de
salaire l'université rémunère uniquement
sa quarantaine de prof permanent et
comme je vous l'ai dit ils sont payés au
lancepierre les autres profs donc Kant
doivent se faire payer en direct par les
élèves et la plupart n'arrivent pas à en
vivre donc ils doivent prendre un emploi
alimentaire à côté mais quand lui veut
gagner sa vie avec ses cours donc au
début il il donne plein de cours
collectifs à l'université plus d'une
vingtaine par semaine et il donne en
plus des cours particuliers avec la
préparation des cours il n'arrête pas et
comme il n'y a pas assez de demande pour
une vingtaine d'heures de cours de philo
par semaine Kant enseigne d'autres
matières il enseigne par exemple la
géographie la mécanique l'hydraulique
l'arithmétique la géométrie ou encore la
trigonométrie Kant ne devait pas être le
meilleur prof de physique de tous les
temps mais l'objectif pour lui c'est
surtout de mettre du beurre dans les
épinards et à force de travail il y
parvient il gagne assez pour ne plus
avoir à emputer sa biblio
de plus en plus d'étudiants sont séduits
par ce prof réputé pour sa supériorité
intellectuelle on dit de lui dans
l'université qu'il est un excellent
cveau et puis il est original il ne se
contente pas de lire un manuel il
digresse raconte des anecdotes il
prétend même apprendre aux étudiants à
penser il leur dit vous n'apprendrez pas
de moi la philosophie mais à philosopher
non pas simplement des pensées à répéter
mais à penser il est si difficile de
gagner sa vie en donnant des cours à
l'université qu'attirer des étudiants
est déjà un succès pour Kant et la
concurrence est en fait parce qu'il y a
trop de prues par rapport au nombre
d'élèves la concurrence est telle que le
succès de Kant fait des jaloux au bout
d'un moment les cours de Kant sont
pleins et dans le même temps d'autres
profs voient leur business périclité ces
concurrents jaloux se mettent à le
critiquer devant leurs élèves c'est bon
signe Kant a été élevé dans un milieu
piétiste le piétisme c'est une nouvelle
version du protestantisme qui se
développe en Allemagne au 17e et 18e
siècle et qui insiste notamment sur la
nécessité de mener une vie morale au
quotidien plutôt que d'adhérer à des
théories précises par exemple les
piétistes interdisent de jouer aux
cartes ils disent carrément que les
cartes sont le livre de prière du diable
et que jouer au cartes est un chemin qui
mène directement en enfer et bien ça
n'empêche pas compte de beaucoup jouer
au cartes à partir de ces études
universitaire il aime tellement jouer au
cartes qu'il dira même dans une
conférence que jouer au cartes rend
l'homme meilleur en lui apprenant à
maîtriser ses émotions cette anecdote
montre que Kant n'est pas l'homme
aostère qu'on imagine ses livres sont si
abstraits est si rigoureux qu'on se dit
que leur auteur ne connaît que les
livres et la pensée qu'il n'a pas de vie
sociale et bien rien n'est plus faux
Kant est même un homme mondain
c'est-à-dire qu'il fréquente volontiers
l'élite sociale de kenigberg il en est
même une figure centrale s'il évolue
dans ce milieu c'est surtout grâce à sa
relaxtion avec la dernière famille dont
il a été le précepteur celle du compte
kaiserlink la comtesse en particulier
est très éprise de Kant il est toujours
le bienvenue au Palace des kaiserlink il
peuttit dîner n'importe quand mais en
fait Kant est invité par la plupart des
familles de l'élite locale dans sa
trentaine Kant est tellement mondain
qu'il est rarement chez lui il passe la
plupart des après-midis à jouer au
cartes ensuite il est invité à dîner
quelque part et il passe la soirée à
discuter ou à jouer aux cartes si bien
qu'il rentre souvent chez lui après
minuit les rares fois où il est invité
nulle part il mange au restaurant si
Kant est un habitué des cercles mondains
c'est parce qu'il est très agréable les
gens en particulier les femmes se
sentent bien dans sa compagnie non
seulement il est très intéressant grâce
à sa vaste culture mais il est très
sympathique et quand ne se laisse n-ce
pas hé par les mondanités il pense que
sa vie sociale très active est bénéfique
à ses amis qui passent beaucoup de temps
dans les livres il dit qu'on ne séduque
véritablement que par la fréquentation
de ses semblables une autre raison de la
popularité de Kant dans les mondanités
c'est son élégance les gens qui le
fréquentent disent qu'il est très bel
homme le cororsvelt les cheveux blonds
une belle peau qui donne une impression
de fraîcheur des yeux dont même les
hommes remarquent la beauté en plus Kant
s'habille avec des vêtements élégants et
finement décorés bref on est loin de la
caricature du philosophe univers
itire d'après Kant un homme atteint la
maturité à 40 ans il peut-être
intelligent bien plus tôt par exemple
dans sa vingtaine mais c'est seulement à
40 ans qu'il a acquis assez d'expérience
qu'il a connu une diversité de
situations suffisante pour enfin
comprendre l'existence et le monde dans
leur complexité la personnalité atteint
sa forme finale à 40 ans bon c'est
peut-être vrai pour beaucoup de gens
mais ça révèle surtout que la
quarantaine est un tournant pour Kant
lui-même il connaît une crise
existentielle et à l'issue de cette
crise le beau professeur mondain devient
le grand penseur il y a plusieurs
raisons à cette mutation tout d'abord
l'environnement social de Kant change
son meilleur ami de l'époque meurt les
liens avec d'autres amis se distendent
et Kant se fait de nouveaux amis ensuite
il a l'impression qu'il est en train de
gâcher son potentiel il a beaucoup
d'idées sur beaucoup de sujets mais il
ne peut pas se faire un nom en
philosophie en passant son temps dans
les dîners mondains et en jouant au
carartte alors que dans sa vingtaine on
disait de lui qu'il était un excellent
cerveau dans sa quarantaine on ne le
voit plus que comme un homme du monde
mais la quarantaine marque pour quant
une nouvelle étape dans sa vie jusqu'à
40 ans l'esprit accumule les matériaux
intellectuels ingère et digère à partir
de 40 ans l'esprit est mû pour créer la
quarantaine est donc une renaissance
pour Kant mais cette renaissance se
produit-elle d'elle-même pas vraiment
pardon pour l'interruption mais j'ai une
question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont il parl bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de
grand-chose et oui il y a 24 4 He dans
une journée et il faut travailler manger
dormir et sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets vous savez vous avez lu
Renant comme moi mais ils se gardent
bien d'en parler les gens qui les
découvrent réussissent à développer
rapidement et facilement leur culture
générale parce que leur rapport au
savoir a changé et une fois qu'ils
appliquent les cinq secrets ils
comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ils savent
s'exprimer avec profondeur sur n'importe
quel sujet ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations et dans les
débats et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d'esprit critique ça
vous intéresse et bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets et je vous explique
comment les appliquer dès aujourd'hui
pour vous cultiver 10 fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo Kant et un de ses nouveaux amis
prévoi de faire une sortie en calèche à
la campagne le lendemain à 8h du matin
le jour suivant son ami est là à
l'attendre à 7h45 à 8h quand n'est
toujours pas là que fait son ami il part
dans la calèche et qui la calèche
rencontre-t-elle sur le chemin Kant il
fait signe à la calèche de s'arrêter
c'estes mouvements sont si vigoureux que
le cocher et le passager le voi
forcément mais voilà son ami dit au
cocher de ne pas s'arrêter ça c'est un
ami oui et pas n'importe lequel Joseph
Green est l'homme à l'origine de la
renaissance de Kant sans cet ami le
professeur ne serait pas devenu le grand
penseur Kant et Joseph green se lit pile
quand le philosophe a 40 ans qu' a-t-il
de si spécial ce nouvel ami et bien
c'est un homme d'une une incroyable
discipline la régularité c'est-à-dire le
fait de répéter les mêmes actions et la
ponctualité c'est-à-dire le fait de
maîtriser son temps avec exactitude la
régularité et la ponctualité sont la
religion du nouvel ami de Kant sa
discipline est si sévère qu'il est
devenu un personnage de comédie comme le
dit Berkson le rire est du mécanique
plaqué sur du vivant et bien Joseph
Green est comme un robot programmé alors
qu'un individu normal et sain à mon avis
s'arrêterait pour accueillir son ami
dans la calèche gre lui est incapable de
s'adapter à un imprévu par amitié dans
cette scène sa discipline extrême est
risible mais elle lui donne un avantage
dans les affaires en effet Joseph green
n'est pas un universitaire mais un
marchand anglais le meilleur marchand
anglais de kenigberg et pourtant les
affaires ne sont pas sa passion sa
passion ce sont les livres d'où son
affinité avec Kant Joseph green vit
comme un ermite érudi il passe la
plupart de son temps à se cultiver chez
lui et il organise son existence selon
des règles ultra strictes Kant et lui
deviennent inséparable ils sont si
ponctuels que les voisins de Green
règlent leur horloge quand Kant sort de
la maison de son ami ce n'est donc pas
Kant le professeur mondain qui influence
son ami c'est green l'Hermite érudit
psychorigide qui déteint sur Kant et pas
qu'un peu Kant devient lui aussi obsédé
par les règles plus précisément par ce
qu'il appelle les maximes c'est-à-dire
des règles de conduite des principes
d'action et c'est cette image de lui que
gardera la postérité donc c'est Joseph
green le marchand anglais qui a fait le
Kante que nous connaissons c'est son
exemple son influence qui ont tiré Kant
des mondanités et qui l'ont réaligné
avec son ambition intellectuelle Kant
dira même que Green lui a donné son avis
sur chaque phrase de la Critique de la
raison pure le chef-d'œuvre qui le fera
entrer dans l'histoire de la pensée il
suffit parfois d'une rencontre pour
rencontrer son
destin dans la quarantaine Kant
rencontre une aristocrate de vestfally
cette femme ne s'est pas rendue seule à
kenixberg elle est accompagnée par une
belle jeune femme à laquelle Kant est S
sensible il se voit à de multiples
reprises et se plaisent l'un l'autre le
temps passe et Kant se met à penser
qu'elle pourrait bien être plus qu'une
amie un jour il se sent enfin prêt à
faire une offre de mariage seulement
voilà ce jour même la jeune femme est en
train de passer la frontière elle rentre
chez elle c'est donc raté mais ce n'est
pas la première fois que Kant rate sa
chance parce qu'à l'égard du mariage il
est indéci pourtant il plaît aux femmes
il est un bel homme sympathique il est
professeur à l'université et il est
apprécié au sein de l'élite sociale de
kenigberg où les occasions de mariage ne
manque pas s'il avait vraiment voulu se
marier il aurait certainement réussi
mais non pourquoi Kant ne se marie-t-il
pas au départ disons jusqu'à la
trentaine c'est à cause de l'argent Kant
calcule qu'il ne gagne pas assez pour
soutenir financièrement une famille mais
à l'époque c'est le sort de beaucoup
d'universitaires les rares à franchir le
pas sont ceux qui dénichent de riches
veuves plus le temps avance plus Kant
devient sceptique à l'égard du mariage
lui-même au milieu de la carantaine il
voit ce qui est arrivé à certains de ses
amis et il ne veut pas connaître le même
sort il ne veut pas se le faire dominer
par une jeune femme capricieuse et puis
enfin il y a aussi l'influence de son
nouveau meilleur ami le psychorigide
Joseph green qui est évidemment un
célibataire dès lors Kant considère que
ce marier n'est même plus une option il
devient même allergique à cette idée
s'il anticipe qu'on va lui en parler
lors d'un dîner il préfère ne pas se
rendre à ce dîner donc Kant restera
célibataire jusqu'au bout sa situation
financière s'améliorera avec le temps
mais il restera dans la misère
sentimentale et
sexuelle nous sommes au début des années
1780 quant à la soixantaine cela fait
seulement une dizaine d'années qu'il a
été nommé prof titulaire et là il
commence à craindre de perdre son poste
pourquoi parce qu'il devient célèbre en
Allemagne pour son athéisme son
chef-dœuvre la Critique de la raison
pure est sortie il y a quelques années
et ce livre commence seulement à
rencontrer le succès espéré mais le
problème c'est que c'est un succès
nourri par la controverse en fait ce
n'est pas possible autrement parce que
les gens ne comprennent pas la Critique
de la raison pure c'est bien trop
compliqué si ce livre gagne en notoriété
c'est parce qu'on dit qu'il contient des
idées subversives les panflets se
multiplient on accuse Kant de prêcher
l'immoralité s'il se laisse faire il va
avoir des problème comment réagit-il à
une attaque collective il faut une
réponse collective Kant organise la
repost avec ses partisans il les
autorise puis les incite à vulgariser et
à défendre son système et avec le temps
leur participation n'est plus vraiment
comment dire libre la défense du
quantisme prend une dimension quasi
mafieuse j'exagère un peu mais quant se
comporte presque en chef de gang
philosophique il n'accepte plus qu'on le
contredise et il est obsédé par son
territoire intellectuel il se rend
compte que lorsque ses partisans
prennent la plume pour défendre la
Critique de la raison pure et bien ça
marche ses idées gagnent du terrain dans
l'opinion du coup Kant encourage ses
disciples et ses amis à le faire puis
les encouragements deviennent des coups
de pression les amis dégoûtés par cette
méthode s'éloignent de Kant mais grâce à
son nouveau prestige philosophique il
conserve des disciples qui acceptent
d'aller au combat pour lui parfois le
missionné est réticent il a d'autres
autes choses à faire et puis il en a
déjà fait assez pour mériter l'attention
et la considération du maître que fait
Kant il force son disciple à prendre la
plume cette anecdote montre que la
qualité des idées ne suffit probablement
pas à les imposer dans l'esprit des
hommes comme avec une religion il faut
des disciples fidèles qui prêche la
bonne parole et qui la défendent
agressivement contre les idées
concurrentes à 70 ans Kant reçoit une
réprimande officielle du roi de Prusse
il ne doit plus discréditer la religion
dans écrit sans effort de votre part
vous devez vous attendre à des mesures
désagréables pour votre obstination
continue ces menaces sont sérieuses Kant
pourrait être mis à la retraite et privé
de revenus ou même forcé à l'exil lui
qui a passé toute sa vie à kenixberg il
n'a pas envie d'en partir à 70 ans il ne
se met pas en mode Lèchebotte pour
autant en particulier il n'a pas peur de
perdre sa pension il est financièrement
indépendant parce qu'il a investi ses
revenus intelligemment il n'est pas
riche mais il est dans l'aisance
financière l'argent n'est plus un souci
pour lui c'est donc donc sans
génuflexion que Kant promet de ne plus
écrire sur les questions religieuses
cette anecdote illustre l'irréigion de
Kant c'est-à-dire que non seulement il
n'a pas de conviction religieuse mais il
n'hésite pas à s'écarter de la doctrine
religieuse officielle dans ses discours
il n'est pas seulement vu comme até à
cause de mauvaise interprétation de ces
livres bien au contraire il prend des
précautions à l'écrit pas dans sa vie
personnelle les gens qui le fréquentent
l'entendent souvent se moquer de la
prière et d'autres pratiques religieuses
il déteste la religion organisée ses
amis ont également compris qu'ils ne
croi pas en Dieu pourtant ses parents
l'avaient éduqué dans la religion mais
la seule chose qui est restée du
piétisme de sa famille c'est sa
discipline personnelle en fait Kant est
un philosophe des Lumières il n'attaque
pas la religion frontalement comme
Voltaire mais il contribue à promouvoir
l'idéal des lumières essentiellement la
foi en le pouvoir de la raison il
contribue à promouvoir cet idéal à
kenigberg à partir de la cinquantaine
quant a de gros problèmes de digestion
il ne cherche pas à les dissimuler au
contraire il en parle à ses invités et
même dans des soirées mondaines ce qui
provoque des éclats de rire pourquoi
est-ce que les gens rient parce que Kant
est hypocondriaque donc la manière dont
il décrit ses symptômes trahit une
obsession qui est comique mais cette
obsession n'est pas sortie de nulle part
quant a toujours eu une santé fragile il
a un corps petit 1 m 57 est frê il a du
mal à respirer à cause de quoi il ne
peut pas supporter de grands efforts
physiques il a aussi pas mal d'allergies
par exemple un journal tout fraîchement
imprimé le fait éternué quant est
conscient de sa fragilité donc il vit
avec prudence il ne fait pas d'excès à
partir de la cinquantaine il limite ses
problèmes digestifs en suivant un régime
strict ses amis disent qu'il va écrire
une critique de la cuisine Kant n'a
jamais été en parfaite santé dans sa vie
mais grâce à sa prudence il n'a jamais
de gros soucis seulement il est obsédé
par ses soucis de santé il en est
conscient et il est conscient de l'effet
psychologique délétaire de son obsession
mais l'hypochondrie est une mode à la
fin du 18e siècle elle est
particulièrement en vogue parmi les
intellectuel qui l'associe à la
mélancolie il n'est donc pas étonnant
que Kant et plusieurs de ses amis se
disent hypochondrique son seul véritable
gros problème de santé il n'en aura pas
conscience il perd la tête à la fin de
sa vie dans sa dernière décennie ses
facultés mentales déclinent et il
devient insomniaque déjà que ces livres
étaient difficiles à comprendre mais ces
derniers textes contiennent carrément
des incohérence il invente des théories
farfelues il se fait arnaquer par un
domestique parce qu'il ne reconnaît plus
les pièces et les billets c'est tragique
l'excellent cerveau de l'Université de
Kenigsberg un des plus grands penseurs
de l'Occident est vaincu par la maladie
d'Alzheimer
Meur si vous aimez l'esprit de cette
vidéo à savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivé en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en science
politique en psychologie en sciences en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne serez urez plus
jamais à cours de choses à dire et vous
gagnerez la confiance nécessaire pour
briller en toute circonstances vous
pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore en tapant
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche mais
je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme et
d'écouter ce que les membres ont à en
dire Valentine qui reconnaît l'énorme
quantité de travail que ce programme a
représenté pour moi dit je cite que
c'est une véritable mine d'or
l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
il a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres est pertinent et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
dipl diplomate la semaine dernière elle
a déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ses discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusé vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans les
commentairire si vous rejoignez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserai intégralement si
vous estimez que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture générale si vous
voulez en savoir plus cliquez sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré partie de
ce programme et je seraai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1idé de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la
[Musique]
pensée